welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldier episode 5 revealed the major
cameo of beloved sitcom star of seinfeld
and v
julia louis dreyfus as contessa
valentina allegra de fontaine
or val a marvel comics deep cut leaving
casual viewers and comic nerds alike
as confused as john walker pounding our
desks and rage willing ourselves to try
to understand
i understand that i understand that oh
god i don't understand it much like her
blank business card this episode leaves
little indication of her background
allegiances or motives
yet here at new rockstars we know how to
zoom and enhance on these clues flip on
the blacklight of our conspiracy
thinking
part a red arrow on it and to do sweat
fan theory you should cling to until
marvel studios inevitably ralph boners
you
boner and i believe contessa valentina
allegra defonteen
is following in the footsteps of nick
fury to assemble a team of morally
clouded anti-heroes to do the jobs the
avengers couldn't
and shouldn't and i actually think we
have a good idea of who will be on that
team
so defontaine's comics history really
leaves the door fully open like you
could look at her brief stint as madame
hydra to conclude that she could be the
head of a hydra comeback in the mcu
but defontaine's hydra arc was really a
mission to undermine hydra
and was really a small part of a much
broader history as a shield spy
working with nick fury and agent 13
sharon carter i agree that hydra never
truly left the mcu always lurking in the
shadows like i tape over my webcam so
that i don't end up on artem zola's
pervert list
i just think there are more
forward-looking reasons to bring allegra
defontaine into the mcu and all we have
to go on is what defontaine says to john
walker
first she sympathizes with him over
executing nico
i would have killed a bastard too i mean
you would have been doing him a favor if
you'd taken out the whole lot
but these guys and ties
you know they got a whole thing to
protect and by
guys in ties she paints herself as
anti-politician
meaning she either works in the private
sector or some shadowy government branch
with such high security clearance that
she looks down on public oversight and
considers cold-blooded killing as a
necessary show of force
she also says you did the right thing
taking the serum of course i know about
that it has made you
very very valuable to certain people
defontaine and her connections
are recruiting super soldiers like
walker ones without loyalties
ones awaiting new orders and yeah she
knows
secrets like walker did not disclose his
serum dosage to his governmental
overseers
but somehow defontaine knows state
secrets few others do
like for example don't worry about the
shield i know you don't have it there's
a little
dirty state secret it doesn't really
belong to the government
it's kind of a legal gray area and by
legal gray area she might be referring
to the fact that the shield
old cap gave sam an endgame the one that
walker killed nico with
technically came from an alternate
timeline going by the director's
explanation of cap living his life with
peggy in a branch history and loki now
seems to be doubling down on that same
timeline logic now the broader public in
the mcu doesn't appear to know about
old cap or the details of the quantum
time travel and in-game
judging by that museum exhibit that says
cap simply retired after in-game
but it sounds like defontaine might know
more about old cap at least enough to
give tourists answers about whether or
not cap is on the moon but before i
continue the brands of big soap that you
use
daily are packed with harmful chemicals
and most of them smell like it too it's
like getting a bouquet of fake flowers
that
burn your nose well dr squatch is
changing the hygiene game with their
natural healthy products that will make
you feel like a man and smell like a
champion they've got some great scents
like grapefruit ipa
it's got kind of a citrusy and piney
note that you'd expect from a craft brew
but in a bar of soap i also like this
deep sea goat's milk
they have a ton of other great scents as
well like a spearmint basil
alpine sage wood barrel bourbon all of
dr squatch's soaps are made in the usa
using the finest ingredients nature has
to offer just look on the label and
you'll recognize everything in there
hundreds of thousands of men already
subscribed to dr squatch meaning every
month fresh bars of squats
show up at their door if you use dr
squatch and can honestly say it's not
the best bar of soap you've ever used
they will send you your money back no
questions asked i've been showering with
dr squash soap for the last month and
it's brought a little bit of joy to my
routine it leaves my skin feeling
refreshed and smelling like a clean man
and not the stale potpourri from your
grandma's house new customers can get 20
off on orders of 20 more when you use
the promo code
dsc new rockstars 20. click on the link
in the description below again that's 20
off on orders of 20
or more check it out with the link in
the video's description in my episode 5
breakdown i pointed out that colored
streak
in defontaine's hair as a possible nod
to victoria hand a character who
appeared in agents of shield though
according to kevin feige not exactly mcu
canon the way the disney plus marvel
series are in the comics victoria hand
works with norman osborne
during the dark rain era when osborne
oversees all of national security
including groups like the thunderbolts
now previously the thunderbolts were
introduced way earlier as a group of
villains pretending to be heroes led by
zemo as citizen v until that team turns
on zemo
and become legit redemptive anti-heroes
but dark rain
transitions the thunderbolts into the
dark avengers which is more or less
osborne's personal hit squad
a group later led by us agent john
walker
and now i believe marvel studios is
adapting this storyline here but
since norman osborne remains a
spider-man adjacent sony property and
sony has signaled a future of limited ip
sharing with disney by signing a deal
with disney's streaming rival netflix
marvel's keeping it simple and just
swapping in
a different government security
authority in his place thaddeus
thunderbolt ross
and i pointed out how ross's name has
been appearing in the credits of the
falcon the winner soldier according to
thaddeus ross all information regarding
the
enhanced humans acts has been reported
to be classified by major donovan of
special
unit just reminding us that ross has
been eager to build his own super
soldier program using that serum ever
since the days of the incredible hulk
film
and we know from ross's role as
secretary of state and avengers handler
of sorts in civil war infinity war and
his cameo at tony stark's funeral and
in-game that this guy might have more of
an ear to the ground about things like
steve rogers whereabouts he could be the
very interested persons that val was
referring to
and now the dormilage is saying that
they're bringing zemo to the raft prison
the facility overseen by thaddeus ross
in civil war and we know that ross will
appear in black widow
and according to some unknown source
cited by vanity fair so
might julie louis dreyfus though that
has not been reported by anyone else but
even still with zemo headed to ross's
raft
prison and walker possibly headed there
too after going rogue
it could lead to both of these inmates
being given a chance to work
on a new team under the supervision of
defontaine
and thunderbolt ross aka the mcu
thunderbolts or
dark avengers so we got baron zemo and
us agent john walker that makes two
who else could be on this team well if
these events do cross over with black
widow
this team could also include yelena
bulova and
taskmaster ross's previous asset emil
blonsky abomination is confirmed to
return to the mcu in the upcoming
she-hulk
this could be his way back in the mcu
avastar ghost
remains active after ant-man and the
wasp a movie that also left the loose
end of sunny birch's mysterious
buyer could that be connected to
whatever this shadowy organization that
ross and defontaine are part of
and hell the witch agatha harkness is
chilling over in west view new jersey
so there you have it one possible lineup
of the mcu's thunderbolt slash dark
avengers whatever name they want to use
a group of assassins overseen by
thaddeus ross and contessa valentina
allegra defonteen
no public accountability no higher
ideals to fight for
avengers who avenge without seeking true
amends
oh by the way i am wearing our anarchy
assembled shirt available at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube for breakdowns
of everything marvel thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you